yes you're now live chair
thank you right uh may i
welcome everyone to this meeting of the
torridge district council community and
resources committee
members of the public uh hope you enjoy
watching on youtube
um there is an opportunity for public
contributions but you should have
registered
by now members
will be given the opportunity to speak
including members who are not actually
members of the committee
and i will try and tell you those who
are members of the committee
and those who aren't first of all we'll
deal with apologies
thank you chair apologies received from
councillor mcgoff
with councillor hurley substituting and
apologies from council
laws with councillor hodgson
substituting
thank you thank you
now we have the minutes of the meeting
of the 7th of september and the special
meeting of 5th of october
pages 4 to 17
i will go through as marked on
the top of the page
page one two
three four
five six
seven eight
nine ten
and pages one
two and three
first of all well we've got to have a
recorded vote as to whether we
accept their fair true and correct
record of the meeting
uh councillor christie's raised his hand
councillor christie wants to speak my
apologies
thank you um can i just refer to um item
26.
yep um i did ask whether we could
re-examine
uh taking the victoria park contract for
doing flowers and the gardening etc
back in house it says there this matter
will be discussed in part two under
the gender item 16. um i don't think it
was actually i've looked through
uh part two and i can't see any bit that
refers to that
now it's my fault i should have picked
it up at the time but that was right at
the start of the meeting because part
two right at the end
um i'm not sure what happened to that
i don't know if the officers would like
to say anything
um chair if councillor christie's happy
i can have a word as it was in part two
i can have a
award for them outside of the meeting
because the matter is
in hand being dealt with more widely
okay anyone else wishing to speak
so we'll move to the recorded vote
whether we accept these minutes
thank you chair
chad sorry could we have a proposal in a
second before we
i will propose from the chair a second
council a lot wanting to speak oh just
got a second emotion
okay thank you
okay thank you chair councillor brenton
[Music]
councillor bright or
councillor bushby or
councillor christie
councillor dart
councillor hicks councillor hudson
councillor hurley abstain
councillor hutchins for
councillor james
four councillor lock
and councillor wiseman oh
thank you thank you
that's eleven four oh sorry
eleven four
thank you thanks we now move on
to the um action list
um you have it in front of you
uh on minute number 75
uh i have had a report regarding
torrington
cemetery to say that they have been up
there
and they have at last on some very good
work
so i'm pleased that things have happened
that one can be taken off the list
anyone else wishing to comment on the
action list
nope
but we move on then
that was for noting and we move on to
public
contributions and we have one
alan smith cathy murdock ah
right um i mr
smith is a client of mine so i have to
declare an
interest in this unfortunately we do not
have a vice chairman today
so please can we elect the vice chairman
to take this item
i propose councillor james from the
chair
is there a seconder for that yep i
second that
are there any other proposals
does that need a recorded vote stacy
yes yes chair okay if we could then
please
thank you chair yeah councillor brenton
for councillor bright
or councillor bushby
for councillor hutchins
councillor lot
councillor wiseman oh
that's unanimous no it's not i didn't
vote
oh i'm sorry councillor james i better
go fall then
thank you thank you that's you anonymous
tear
okay i will now stand back and
councillor james will deal with this
martyr
thank you chair so this is a public
contribution
by alan smith or kathy murdock
would you like to state which one you
are and you've got three minutes
to make your point so thank you good
morning to you both
who whichever one is doing it so please
continue
mr smith good morning mr james
um kathy won't be here today um i should
be very quick it's just that
with regard to the recommendation of the
committee for you to consider later on
in this meeting
i'm quite happy to cancel the covenant
as existing and replace it with the
government as described by
the scrutiny committee that's all i have
to say thanks
all right sorry was kathy coming in then
or
or no no no right
okay well if that's it then i'll hand
back to the chair then
thank you bob
sorry is there a problem bob's just
covered smoke right we've
right sorry public contributions forward
plan
okay so
from the forward plan slightly hard to
read
um so we are on
moorings we've got morris policy general
directions
duty holder harbour village square
urgency they're all the agenda for today
it doesn't look like we need anything on
for the next meeting
um so the budget's special in february
i'll take it we don't need anything on
for that
right welcome back bob we've i've just
moved on to the forward plan
just pointed out that today is fairly
full the next meeting looks very full
and we've got budget special in february
so i don't know whether we need to
plan anything that far ahead do we
wouldn't have thought so i
i believe we move on to the next item
right
okay item six declarations of interest
for members of the public to be aware
all members have to
declare their interest in any particular
item when it comes up
as you've just seen me do with
that public participation item
item seven agreement of the agenda
between parts one and two
the agenda does set out quite a few
items of part two
um they seem logical to me
because they involve finances of the
council
and from the chair i'll propose that
that be
accepted as part two items 15 to 18
inclusive is there a second i will
second that
right down the road you're ahead of me
right uh that's got to go to the vote i
believe
thank you chair councillor brenton
or councillor bright
or councillor bushby
sorry for councillor christie
or councillor dart for
councillor hicks for councillor hudson
or councillor hurley or
councillor hutchins councillor james
for councillor lock four
councillor wiseman oh
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you
i to mate urgent matters i have
none so we move on to
item nine moorings and facilities policy
and general directions
for your information just before
lockdown
there was a meeting at barnstable which
we attended
along with north devon district because
they have
african harbor and we had
quite a detailed explanation of the law
and the situation
and it became clear that we have to
organize things better as far as the
harbor is concerned
and there has been a lot of effort put
in
since then to try and bring things
up to speed um
we'll hand over to richard haste um
but i would tell you now you might like
everything he's saying but it's got to
happen
richard
thank you chair thank you committee um
i'll pass you over to
paula buster who's the harbour master
and the expert
um in the in this field obviously for
those who don't know
i've been asked to uh for the interim
just to support paul in the harbour
which used to be sean
um and hopefully continue without going
forward so i'll just pass you over to
paul
to go through the morrison facilities
policy general directions
thank you richard and uh uh thank you
chair for that introduction yeah
um my name is paul lavishtower heart
master benefit of
being hardmaster now for three years um
the moorings and facilities policy and
general directions
uh the purpose of the report is to
present members of the community and
resources committee
the operational moorings and facilities
policy for consideration
and approval um prior to this committee
meeting
uh we had a recommended recommendation
for approver from the biddeford hardware
so this is the
second reading coming through to you
guys um further to that
um we're looking for strategic decision
to be made by today's committee on
implementing general directions
for the safe and efficient management of
the harbour this would be in compliance
with the portland safety code and as uh
council hicks said we've been doing a
lot of work
uh to remain compliant with the port
green safety code
and we do have in march 2021
an obligation to report to the maritime
coast guard agency that
central government we are in fact
compliant with the harbor
with the port marine safety code again
that was also recommended uh for
approval by the harbour board at the
most recent meeting um
you've got the report before your
members uh myself and richard will do
our best to answer any any questions
that you might have
thank you right
i throw it open to the meeting
councillor brenton thank you chair uh
yes i would um
be good if we'd had a sort of map of the
area that it would be covered by
the uh port authority of biddeford
please
to make sure that we we know what which
which areas of the
uh tide height height or low tide area
we're talking
about i presume it's all to do with
um north of the bitter long bridge
nothing south of it
uh yes sir um effectively the
harbour jurisdiction mirrors uh
biddeford uh uh
council um boundaries but to create for
ease of uh
uh for ease of understanding it's
effectively between the two bridges
between the the liberty give or take a
few areas that
are outside of our jurisdiction that is
the area where
uh biddeford harbor authority the owning
authority being torres district council
is the statutory harbor authority so
effectively
between the two bridges councillor right
and so north devon are uh
content with the area for sure then
along from methuen brown close to the
new bridge that right
they they recognize that we have that uh
authority to deal with that
yes that's well understood so yeah yeah
it's well understood
it's just it never used to be that's the
point that's why i'm saying it
there was there was always a problem
really with them at the end of ethel and
brown
close with moorings there
you know so some were moored on torridge
and some were born on north dakota and
we didn't have any authority to deal
with the ones that moored on north
devon's
for sure yes i think
i think there has still been some issues
around
around
some of those moorings we do have a
meeting coming up in the very near
future with
uh various government organizations
including the environment agency natural
england
the national trust and north devon will
be at that meeting so
we do have a meeting coming up in the
very near future where
some of those issues about moorings and
north devon's boundaries will be
discussed at that meeting
you're welcome to have an invitation if
you want to come to that meeting sir
thank you
thank you chair anyone else wishing to
speak
chancellor hudson
thank you chair um it's a very thorough
uh report um i think it's covered every
eventuality
and i'm very supportive of it
my only query is on page 42
item 9
where it states unfortunately applicants
who have a disability do not have
priority over
other people on the waiting list
do we need to actually state this or is
it
that it is an open list for um
anyone who meets the criteria um
i think uh this is
muddying the waters to be honest
and i'd like some comment please
um i think you could be right counsellor
and
happy to take that statement out we just
removed that thing completely
i understand fully where you're coming
from and uh it's not necessary for the
the moorings and facilities policy we
can strike that out madam
thank you very much
okay councillor christie thank you
um i attended the last meeting where we
had the various stakeholders there
uh would it be possible to attend this
forthcoming meeting as well
oh yes yes of course councillor
christopher you'd be more than welcome
sir
thank you if you could send me an invite
that'd be great
yeah we'll do councillor bushby
thank you chair um on page 23
um legal implications right at the start
uh
number three at the top there um partly
down that paragraph
i don't know whether just the way that
i'm reading it but um it says
harvard directions however would only
apply to ships and not
personal watercraft an alternative to
this process would be for the harbor
authority to apply for powers
of general direction through the
hardware revision process
process now the only reason i mentioned
this is because
at a previous meeting council of ford
was looking at ways to
restrict the use of jet skis and
pleasure craft you know speed
restrictions etc
um in apple door well you know if that
actually comes off and we actually start
to drive
um boats further or jet skis not further
up the river
um you know is this something that
is going to create as a problem in the
future or should we actually be
um going down the the road of this
general direction through the harbor
revision process to include personal
watercraft
as well as commercial uh vessels
um to your question councillor
appledore doesn't lie within our
jurisdiction it's outside of the um
authority limits um currently
you know that's exactly why i'm
suggesting what i'm suggesting now
because you know the jet skis use the
equador end of the
estuary but you know if they come
further up into the river
in other words you know the river that
we know from
outside of riverbank house you know uh
or from the new bridge upwards then
i mean presumably that's in the harbor
there is it
um yeah between the between the bridges
yes um
jenkins are a difficulty
summer
hello what's going on not me
i'm not sure jet skis are a problem
uh personal works crafts are a problem
it is a national
issue and there's something i think that
central government's giving a great deal
of thought to i mean and it's based
around
the definition of a vessel uh being
involved in navigation from a to b
and there's been precedent set with uh
personal watercraft
where they're not actually operating
between a and b and there's been a lot
of difficulties in controlling them so
controlling jet skis is a national
problem
uh it's something at the moment we are
not able to
um apply controls to unless
as a report said we went further down
the road
and and applied for harbor revision
order
the general directions which we could
then include personal warfare
but it's not it's a it's another further
bit of work
uh something that we certainly keep we
will explore going forward
in a nutshell mr love story you're
saying it's something we've got to sort
of look at in the future but if we
hold things up for that everything else
gets hold up
that's correct
anyone else wishing to speak
counselor lock
no leather chair counselor leather my
apologies
thank you chair not being a member of
the committee but thanks for letting me
speak
i i thought jet skis were banned from
the harbour
do we not have a bylaw banning them from
the harbor
that's the difficult difficulty we've
got council leather the bylaws that
we've got
currently are dated 1894
and um that's that's the the back end of
the 20th century
and we didn't we didn't have jet skis
then and there's no there's no current
measures to control
jet skis from that and that's why we're
seeking additional powers to be able to
better manage the harbour although there
is this outstanding issue with jet skis
which is a national issue
anyone else wishing to speak
right oh counselor hurley
thank you sir i'm just thinking um would
it not be better to put this policy
through now
and then start working on the jet ski
thing immediately afterwards
once the policy is through surely that's
possible i mean we have heard of
problems with jet skis
it may get it may ease it may get worse
i know council of four was a bit
concerned about it and i remember i
think this came up and i think it was
sean kearney who said
uh there's nothing could be done about
it as uh the harbour masters just said
that we're our hands are tied so surely
we should be looking now
to get something done about it because
it could only get worse in the future
and if it takes
some time to get a policy in um as i say
we should be starting straight away i
would have thought
thank you
paul you any comment all right
oh councillor james yeah thank you chair
as an epidural counselor
um like to express concern but um
somewhat slow
approach to this jet ski problem it's
something in appledorch has built up
very strongly
over well particularly this year and um
i think this council needs to look at a
comprehensive policy for the history
and uh not to talk about sometime in the
future but to look at it very urgently
thank you chair can i just respond to
that
yes and some of the comments so um as
has been mentioned there there is a
there's
an obvious concern about jet ski so uh
members will recall a council afford put
a notice of motion to full council for
us to look into
uh jet skis with a view of bringing
something
in place uh for next
easter so that was the notice of motion
that's what's current that's what will
be
currently looked at and councillor james
shawn
and myself got a meeting with councillor
ford and councillor haynes tomorrow
morning
the feeling i get from the committee is
that we really must push
forward with the jet ski problem
which may well force us into
going for this powers of general
direction
through a harbor revision process but in
the meantime
we do need to move on with this document
i would have thought
so i'll propose its adoption from the
chair
is there a secondary
i'm i'm happy right okay
i'm having trouble with putting my hand
up okay
counselor james is second did i get that
clear
yeah anyone else wishing to speak
well let's put it to the vote then
please
thank you chair councillor brenton
he's away from his oh he's just coming
back now justine
thank you councillor brenton
he's trying to mute i believe
there you go right it wouldn't it
wouldn't unmute
it used a 14-pound hammer on it but it
still wouldn't work
right yeah four thank you
councillor bright four
councillor bushby or
councillor christie or councillor dart
or councillor hicks or
councillor hudson subject to the removal
of
that item i mentioned thank you
thank you councillor hurley or
councillor hutchins councillor james
or councillor locke four
councillor wiseman oh
that's unanimous chair thank you
and yes i think that item is mutually
agreed by all that be removed councillor
hodgson
thank you item 10
the port marine safety code
this came up at that
long meeting at north devon and it
became
obvious that torridge had no provision
for this
whatsoever and it did look to be a big
problem there's been huge discussions as
to
who is actually responsible
and this proposal is to
put right a glaring gap which we have in
our paperwork
uh who's taking it richard
jerry once again paul being the expert
i'll let him do
his report uh
thank you chairman um as you've quite
rightly
pointed out um there's been a a gap in
our
in our in our management of reporting in
safety code and it is in in relationship
to who the duty holder is
as you quite rightly pointed out we had
a back in february pre-coded
we had a training session um where
where members attended and officers
attended them and it became apparent
that we needed to
appoint a duty holder you've got the
report there before you for discussion
uh as the chairman said we've given a
lot of thought to this about
how we could best achieve the duty
holder
and we've come to the conclusion um and
in fact the recommendation is
that members consider this report
and that the formal duty holder for
biddeford harbor authority be the
community
and resources committee itself um
going forward if you if you agree to
that we can we can arrange
further training and to fully clarify
your your role within within the portman
safety code compliance
i'm happy to answer any questions with
richard
as best we can thank you chair
any questions
right well to move it forward i'll
propose its adoption from the chair
is there a second i will second that
counts a lot
thank you councillor james wishing to
speak
are you gonna second it thank you thank
you
no one else wishing to speak we'll take
a formal vote on this one please
thank you chair councillor brenton or
cancer bright ball
councillor bushby
or councillor christie
oh or
councillor hicks or councillor hodgson
councillor harley or councillor hutchins
or councillor james or
councillor locke or councillor wiseman
oh thank you that's unanimous chair
thank you right we move on to agenda
item
number 11. so i hand over to councillor
james to
chair this one all right
thanks thank you sorry check can we just
have a i have a vote for councillor
uh james to chair this this agenda item
you've done that the government yeah
well we did it for the public
contributions and then
um councillor hicks took the chair again
so we'll need to do a further vote for
councillor james to chair this
item agenda i propose counselor james
takes the chair
seconded councillor hudson
right you better go to the vote then
please
kirsty isn't it thank you chair
councillor branson or
councillor bright or councillor bushby
or councillor christie oh
councillor dart did why can't we cheers
for councillor hudson
oh counselor harley
poor councillor hutchings or
councillor james or councillor lock
or councillor wiseman or
thank you that's unanimous chair
all right thank you kirsty um so thank
you bob
i'll take over chair right i take it
sean's doing this
to introduce it thank you chair yes i'll
cover this one for you so
um members will of course be familiar
with their previous decision
to not remove the uh restrictive
covenant on the hotel site in westwood
ho
and that that decision was called to
scrutiny
um so on the 29th of september scrutiny
internal scrutiny had a a debate about
that
decision and an alternative
recommendation was proposed by
councillor inch
the second did by councillor haynes and
that is that the community resources
committee be asked to consider removing
the existing covenant and putting on a
new covenant
requiring that the land is used for
commercial use only
so that is the purpose of this report it
is for you to
debate and resolve on the recommendation
from ons
thank you thank you sean
so we're throwing open to debate and
you're debating
the decision that come from ons
and the implications for that report all
right coach the bike you wish to speak
thank you jeff i just wanted to check
one detail uh with the change of use
from a hotel
uh to commercial use allow the applicant
to build flats
on its own because i don't feel the
community would appreciate flats any
more than a hotel
but if the economic benefit of having a
hotel compared to having flats would be
significant to the area so i want to
make sure
we get this nailed down
all right um i don't know
we need to answer that yeah residential
properties
would not fall within the definition of
commercial uh
use councillor bright
so there's no way he'd build flats on
their own
he could but could he um build like make
a business with flats above
commercial wouldn't allow any
residential so if the flats were
residential
um that wouldn't fall within the
definition obviously businesses above
yes that's a commercial but purely um
flats for
residential use wouldn't be allowed onto
this definition
okay all right cool okay i'm sorry you
come up quite quick then but cancer
hurley
thank you chair i think stacy may have
answered my question because
i thought occurred to me yeah okay you
can't build flats and have them as
residential use but supposing you build
the flats
and a commercial company or an insurance
company pension fund buys them
and then rents them that's surely a
commercial venture as opposed to
residential um just a point obviously
yeah right
um can i come back a chair does yeah
stacy does that make a difference if
like an insurance company buys the
property and then rents them out
because that's a commercial venture as
opposed to i know it's residential
people staying there but it's a business
which is operating under that guys
so thank you council hurley it's the use
that we're concerned with so they
wouldn't be allowed to be
used for residential use regardless as
to who's um owning or operating them
so that that again would fall into the
residential definition which is outside
um this suggestion and and the
government would actually state that
with it there's no residential use
whatsoever
whether it's private residential or as a
company
yeah the land must be used for
commercial use only so flats would fall
into
a residential use um which wouldn't be
allowed
thank you thank you chad right uh
counselor christie
you think i think the point is just
being answered actually but
um when this first came up the hotel was
going to be i think five stories
um if it's commercial i assume this is
going to be lower
um can i ask would this will be decided
at any later planning application stage
because
uh i don't know if other councils have
had complaints but i get quite a few
the the block of flats right on the
seafront just
next to this site completely uh shades
out the promenade and it makes it quite
cold and i'd hate to see a tall block
put here whatever commercial use
overshadowing are green which is a very
popular area
that will presumably come up a planning
stage with it and will the
planning appeal when inspector put a
limit on the height will that still
apply to any new building
to planning aspects of that yes to in
response to council christie
yes of course these matters are would be
considered in any future planning
application
and the height scale mass of the
building it would be also a really
important consideration so
yes and that advice from uh obviously
appeal
um decisions uh help planners
when when looking into the
recommendations they they guide us on
our decision making don't they so
yes obviously that uh appeal decision is
an important one
all right thank you sean uh counselor
lock
yeah i've got great concerns about this
actually i mean on page 49 it says the
fact that planning permission for a
hotel
not been welcomed by members or
residents is completely irrelevant
because that's what was applied for and
that was
what permission was um given for
but when we talked about classes and
commercial
um as from the first of september 2020
there were changes in the classes
um like new class eve which encompasses
commercial business and services and i
pick up on
council earnings point that if a
commercial entity took up it may well
revert to residential they may be able
to tie it
um to the commercial you so i've got
great concerns with the change of um
the classes at the moment okay
all right um okay thank you cursed a lot
coaster brenton
thank you chair well i know uh
councillor hurley council a lot just
raised points that i'm concerned with as
well about the commercial element of
um flats or you know apartments
holiday apartments i mean this this is a
it's going to lead to some really
bad scenes in the future because we've
had this before at westwood however
uh what is holiday and then what becomes
residential
the thing is that um we're in the
driving seat here surely over the
covenant business of
taking out councillor christie's point
about the height we can determine that
now
it doesn't have to be a planning issue
if we're if we've got a saying
what actually goes there because we we
sit on the covenant
and i do think that if we looking at
commercial it can't include
holiday flats in there because that is
just a thin end of the wedge
seen it all before
thank you council brenton stacy do you
want to come in again or
no i
i don't think so chair thank you unless
there's any other specific questions
um yeah okay um
councillor hudson you've got your hand
up
yes i've got i've got a legal question
for stacey with regard to the removal of
one covenant
and uh the creation of a new covenant
um we have we've been this has been
proposed but there is no sort of
explanation of how this actually works
in practice
does uh the lifting of one covenant
and the subsequent creation of a new
covenant
dovetailed together is there any
uh requirement for the new covenant
before it is put in place to be
presented
again creating a gap in
proceedings or does this work uh
together so um i'd like some clarity on
that please
thank you thank you council hodgson we'd
do it simultaneously so we would
make the application to remove the
current covenant at the same time
as making the application to um install
the new covenant so one wouldn't be
removed
and the current one wouldn't be removed
without the new one being
registered if that makes sense but it
will be a
simultaneous transaction thank you for
that clarification
council brenton you want to come back
again uh yes i would propose that we
defer this and get a better report on
this because this is not good enough i'm
afraid
for for such a significant development
that could take place in western health
i do believe we need to be absolutely
clear as
what can or cannot go on this site
and who actually controls that
especially with the categories
and that's especially as councillor lock
has pointed out over the business of
categories being changed
um vis-a-vis commercial
so that's my proposition that it would
be deferred and get a better report of a
further a fuller report
thank you secondary for that
uh council hurley you've got your hand
up yeah i would second that chair um
i i'm uneasy uh with what
council locks has been saying here this
morning
i wasn't aware of changes then why would
i be
um and it's just a thought you know we
we have
advice from uh from stacy but i would
like to see it
in writing that there's no way any flats
of any sort can be put here because this
is what people of westwood host
certainly didn't want or don't want
and it's a big decision as council
brenton just said it's a big commitment
this
changing from one covenant to another um
so yeah
i'll i'll certainly second what council
brenton has said we need more more
advice on that all right okay
so can i just go to council lock a
moment please
and then i'm ask stacy something well i
was just going to say the only
the only way to save part of that
position at the moment is to leave the
government as its fans
right thank you councilor stacy um the
recommendation is the member scrutinized
the resolution
it doesn't ask for any decision at all
can we just go with counselor brenton's
proposal
um no we can't
just to clarify so we had the decision
from
cnr not to remove the covenant um
that was called in by the ons committee
who have made a recommendation
that the government covenant is amended
um to allow commercial use
only um if cnr don't agree
with ons recommendation then the
procedure will be
for the matter to be referred to full
council
for full council to decide whether they
want to
go along with cnr's recommendation or
ons recommendation
and would i be writing assuming when it
went to full council there would be a
new report that would take into any
planning changes that could affect
the outcome um no chair
um because the planning process process
is completely separate
and the the only consideration here is
whether or not to remove the covenant or
amend the covenant in relation to ons
recommendation right so if so
at the moment then we
we scrutinize ons um
if we don't support it then it just goes
to full council
and the default position is that the
original decision of full
council or cnr was that that the
covenant stays
cnr wasn't it um chair full council will
decide whether to
um go along with ons recommendation or
um
cnr's recommendation okay right
council wins you wish to speak
thank you chair yes well i was the one
that put this uh
recommendation forward at ons
and my sole intentions to do that was
to stop um uh to only have commercial
use only on this site um
my reasons for doing that was to stop uh
flats being built on the site um
we've also i mean i'm not i'm not a
westworld counselor i
do apologize to councillor hudson's for
for doing it
for for saying that but i i do know
on social media that there has been a
lot of concern
with more flats and more accommodation
and more holiday flats
going down at westborough so my sole
intention was to
alter the covenant so that uh
the covenant won't come off but a new
covenant to be put on for commercial use
only and i think commercial use only is
the
is the right words for i think stacey
has been quite
clear that no way can
flats or holiday flats be built on this
site
thank you chair all right thank you
carson
council brenton well thank you well
in fact if it goes to full council
following uh stacy's um
what she's just said and of course full
council can uh make
all all manner of decisions there
because clearly we can suspend standing
orders in order to do that so
um that would that would be a way
uh forward christie yeah a simple
question but
um mr smith who's already spoken today
uh he offered 120 000 pounds for the
uh removal of the covenant
is he still offering 120 000 pounds just
for the change of the covenant
or not because it doesn't say in our
report
stay safe come in um we haven't
discussed that with
um the valuation with mr smith um
because we felt that it was premature
um if committee um weren't minded to go
forward with
with ons recommendation um
it would have to be valued um i don't
know
if he's gonna still offer 120 000 or not
but we we
if committee were minded to follow that
recommendation then certainly
we we would have that information
brought forward
back up i think it does reinforce
council brenton and councillor hurley's
um query about uh you know more
information
i'd like to know that before i vote on
anything thank you
right stacy so what do we do today we
just note it and
defer a decision and it goes to full
council
chair if committee aren't minded to um
uh approve ons recommendation then it
will go to full council
right so
do sorry council hounds uh
yes just a clarified chair if it goes to
full council because only full council
can ask for a report or can't it
yes of course right thank you
right right then so if nobody's
recommending we accept ons
um recommendation and it doesn't ask
us to um accept it it just asks us to
scrutinize it
then presumably it stays as it is
and it goes to full council stacey you
just clarify
chair i think we need to vote that um
cnr committee today are not going to
approve ons
recommendation and then it would um
refer to full council
um for full council to make the decision
as to whether they want to
stay with cnr's previous recommendation
not to remove the covenant
or um ons recommendation to amend the
government to commercial use only
i'm not sure so i'm going to
ask for a proposal counselor bushby you
want to come in
thank you chair um well i was just going
to point out you know that
clear you know there's currently uh
planning permission for a hotel
there potentially anyway so it's not
like you know there's
what whatever goes there there's a
potential for a building to talk about
it's never going to be
an extension of the village green so
that you've got a greenfield site there
um so you know i'm resigned to the fact
that at some point there will be
a structure of some description there um
and i was just gonna um propose that you
know we've
we've we've got this report from over
roon scrutiny which
is uh saying that we accept the change
um from uh from one
covenant to a a different type
restricting it to commercial as coaster
wrenches said
and i would propose that as long as the
120 000 pounds are still
on the table that we accept that
right um sorry counselor hicks you can't
come in
um right okay well i've had that
proposal from concert bushby so you're
proposing
that we accept o anes's
recommendation that the site
that we changed the covenant which mr
smith has
previously said they would agree to but
we haven't discussed any details
but we would sorry wait a minute
sorry mr chair on a point of view this
is getting a bit confusing here because
to say the least yeah uh
if we should surely be following
the solicitor's advice namely that
what's on the table now is either we
accept ons recommendation
or we use it and that's what we should
be voting on here not
uh an amendment if you like
an unsecond amendment from uh another
councillor that that can't be
that can't be right i propose in that
case and that cnr do not accept
the internal um ons committee's
recommendation
that the mata goes to full council all
right i'd second that
right but did council of bushmeat
was that a proposal from you coaster
bush because you came in
that was a proposal that we accept over
roon scrutiny's
recommendation do we have a second for
that one
well that's a direct negative i don't
think it works well exactly it doesn't
whichever way it goes
right well if nobody's coming then we
would have to accept
chair councillor hurley's raised his
hand oh sorry i would answer that cancer
hurley
thank you chair um yeah i was all for
the recommendation from internal
scrutiny until
it came to my mind that you know
commercial properties do buy buildings
and do rent them
and we need safeguards to make sure that
doesn't happen because that seems to me
to be a huge loophole in this
uh agreement if we change the covenant
which is fine
if we find further down the line there
is a building and it is bought by
somebody else
who using for commercial purposes able
to lease it
for holiday flats or whatever um that's
not good and that's why
i personally would like more information
to ensure
that doesn't happen and this is what i
think council brenton's talking about
uh and maybe one or two others thank you
right okay well we're gonna have to go
to a vote on it
and we go with cancer brandon's uh
rejection of ons
uh recommendation so obviously we go to
the votes stacy on that basis
clarify the vote please chair will you
what we're voting for
well you've just proposed chair that we
reject ons recommendation
to to change the covenant and to make it
for business use
is that what you said jay that was
councillor locke's proposal
[Music]
that's right that's right okay all right
happy with that stacy yes yeah right
okay courtesy we go to the vote um
that we reject ons recommendation
thank you chair councillor brenton four
councillor bright or
councillor bushby against
councillor christie oh
councillor dart for
councillor hit oh sorry councillor
hudson
or cancer hurley or
councillor hutchins
councillor james for councillor locke
four councillor wiseman four
all right okay
you'd like to just give us a result
kirsty please yes
of course it's um ten four and one
against chair
all right thank you very much kirsty
thank you everybody um
i'm back with some relief to coach
are you there bob somebody contact him i
am here
right okay can we move on to
item 12 which is for noting
two decisions made under the urgency
procedure
any comments there too
chancellor christie yes can i
just raise here 64.
no oh yeah maybe just coming off now
uh this is the exception sites um
talked about the element of market
housing uh should be demonstrated
through sp
site-specific evidence of development
viability as
necessary um members of the planning
committee will know that for years i've
been asking that we see
um the district valuers reports on these
liability of sites
we're now getting these exception sites
and some of them are quite large
i have asked is it possible that we can
get the developer
to actually survey the site to pay for a
survey of the site because
what happens at the moment is you get
developers come along
and they put every cost they can think
of into their
plan and lo and behold we don't get any
affordable homes
and it seems that
this is something that needs to be
addressed nationally i think and i
i would like us to have put this in and
say that
you know we we are actually giving
permissions on sites where we don't know
the actual viability and we need to know
the viability
before we give planning permission and
it seems
wrong because clearly we're not meeting
any uh
of our affordable targets and i don't
think anyone throughout the country is
and yet developers are getting away with
this all the time it seems to me
and i know that we have actually
on one occasion i did ask for um
torridge to actually do their own
valuation
and lo and behold we employed an
independent group who came out with
exactly the same figures as a district
valuer
but then uh when i looked through the
figures it became obvious that the one
figure that was missing was extremely
important was how much the developers
have paid for the site
and it does seem loaded against us and i
wonder if we couldn't have put that
somewhere in our response thank you
yes well there's a lot of things in the
document that one might not necessarily
agree with
but the officers had to get it done
councillor haines
maggie chair just following council
christie's um
concerns um i think there may be an
opportunity under the
second order consultation which finishes
on the 29th of october
there's a section on affordable housing
perhaps just councillors look at that
closely and
they've got concerns about the viability
system maybe there's an opportunity
there
to respond thank you
thank you councillor haynes i think that
must be put across to the officers and
they should be able to embody something
anyone else wishing to speak it is for
noting only
do we have to take a vote on the noting
no chad no right
no one wishing to speak i think we can
move
on
we've dealt with the planning one
[Music]
test and trace support payment anyone
wishing to speak
thought so it's fairly obvious
okay if no one's wishing to speak okay
councillor hurley's just raised his
hands sorry counselor harley yeah very
very
briefly chair um i've gone through page
78
and highlighted probably where i'll be
about the sixth point down some around
there
individuals have applied for a
qualifying benefit
but have not yet received a decision or
appealed against the decision not to
award a qualifying benefit and are
awaiting the outcome the appeal
will be eligible to claim now my point
is if they're eligible to claim and they
give them money
if they have what the decision comes
back when they've applied for a benefit
and they're told they can't have it
will they be made to pay the money back
we'll have to pay the money back
do you see what i'm coming for you see
the point i'm
shall i answer that yes please counselor
there's two schemes that there's a
discretionary scheme and
the mandatory scheme as it were so um
individuals who have been hit by
covid and are on a limited income
um would still be eligible under the
discretionary scheme so the answer in
short is no they wouldn't
provided they have have lost their
income due to being
in isolation effectively but it just
depends on what scheme they would fall
under
um effectively hopefully i clarified
that that makes sense but
yeah i understand that but it just it
means you know you can
you can apply for a grant you can get it
and then find afterwards you've been
turned down
that was all i've got i've got no
worries about people having the money if
they need the money i have no worries
whatsoever about that
but it's something we see so often is
that money's paid out
uh which shouldn't have been one way or
another and this was just
something that sort of sprang out to me
when i read through the report
yeah no that they wouldn't be asked to
pay it back if they were eligible for
the benefit they would fall under the
first scheme
and if they were waiting for their
benefits assessment
and then got the benefit they would fall
under the first scheme
and if they didn't get the benefit they
would still qualify into the second
scheme if that makes sense because
if they hit the lower income threshold
they would still be eligible under the
second scheme so we wouldn't be asking
them to pay that 500 pounds back
okay thank you stacy thank you chair
councillor locke
yeah just general comment i did think
that the twenty four thousand pound
medicated for administration can't seem
rather high
i just wonder down that officers came to
that conclusion
uh chair we um would agree that it is
very high
it's the figures that the government
have given us so it's not that torridge
have
allocated ourselves 24 000 for
administration costs that's the money
that the government have awarded
does that one have to be paid back we
don't spend it
no we don't believe so so the government
uh go through a process
called new burdens doctrine so they
evaluate
costs of local authorities implementing
new
schemes nationally so as stacy
said the government awards different
councils different amounts of
sums of money to set up and administer
such schemes
so it's it's not done in an indus
individual authority by authority
basis it's just a national scheme so
it's an estimate of what they think
the costs are of implementing so any i.t
costs and administering the scheme
but there's no indication that any of
that money would need to be
paid back and it hasn't for any of the
other schemes we've implemented
so the indication is we're working on
the cheap well-done
officers coastler leather
thank you chairman it was just on page
78 again the fifth
bullet point down which states the
maximum capital threshold of six
thousand
i've argued for a long time i remember
when this 6000
limit came in that it's far too low for
a poor area like torridge many
authorities have got twelve thousand
fourteen sixteen thousand pound
uh thresholds and we set ours at 000
and that's pathetically low sum that and
i shall never cease
to argue that we ought to increase it to
10 or 12 000 pounds
thanks chair thank you chris
this one's for nothing again no one else
wishing to speak
so i think we can move on now
uh possibly into part two
yes so can we have a formal
movement to go into part two i'll
propose it
is there a second order i'll second it
thank you can we take a formal vote on
it please
thank you chair councillor brunson or
councillor bright or
councillor bushby or councillor christie
or councillor dart
four counselors
councillor hicks yes poor thank you
councillor hudson oh councillor harley
or councillor hutchings
councillor james for councillor locke
or councillor weissman
that's unanimous chair thank you
uh members of the public i'm sorry to
say that we have to leave you at this
stage
you can go on with some work now we've
got to
discuss matters which are financially
relevant